Hi everyone. Right now, everyone is
talking about CloudBot and people are
rushing to buy new Mac Minis or new
dedicated physical hardware just to run
CloudBot 724. But here's the truth, you
don't need to do that. You don't need to
spend $600 to buy a new Mac Mini or
leave your gaming PC up and running all
night. And the best part, we are going
to host it in AWS free tier. It lives in
the cloud. It will never sleep and it
will talk directly with you with your
Telegram or WhatsApp account. Today I am
going to show you how to build your
personal AI agent using Cloudbot. For
those of you who don't know, Cloudbot is
an open source project created by Peter
Steinberger. He designed this app to be
the missing link between the LLMs and
your daily applications. Before we start
setting up Cloud D, I need to be
transparent about you for the costs.
First of all, Cloud D is an open source
free software. The server we are
building today is essentially free if
you are eligible for AWS free tier.
However, the brain of the bot requires
an API key. So, Cloudbot needs an LLM
model to run. This means you will pay
for LLM for what you use per message.
Instead of paying for expensive LLM API
credits, I'm going to power this agent
with my Google Gemini API. But why?
Because Google Cloud currently offers
$300 credits and a free trial for 90
days. This means you can run this
powerful AI agent completely for free to
start with. So, let's get started. All
right, let's prepare our server. First
of all, log to your AWS console. Then go
to the EC2 section. In the EC2 section,
click launch instance to configure our
server details. Firstly, we need to give
a name to our virtual server. I named
this virtual machine as my_cloudbot_vm.
I'm choosing Ubuntu for the operating
system. For the instance type, you can
search for the free tier eligible ones.
If you search for the free, you can find
the free available virtual machines. I
do not recommend you to go with the
T3.micro.
I started provisioning this virtual
machine but since it is memory is 1 GB,
it doesn't let me to install the bot. So
I advise you to use a 4 gig or 8 gig
memory virtual machines. I will choose
the C7i with the 4 GB memory one. So I
just selecting this virtual machine.
Don't forget to create a new key pair to
connect your virtual machine. Just click
the create new key pair. Give a name
your key pair and create the key pair.
It will download a file with the PAM
extension. For the network settings,
just make sure that SSH traffic is
allowed. We do not need to open any
other ports. So, we are ready. Just
click the launch instance to create our
virtual machine. That's all. We created
our virtual machine successfully. Now,
let's continue with the installation of
cloud debot. Since the instance is
launched, let's SSH into this virtual
machine. It's very easy to connect to a
virtual machine in AWS. Just click the
instance ID and then just click the
connect button. AWS has EC2 instance
connect function which you will be able
to connect to your virtual machine
through the browser through SSH
connection. So once I click the connect
button, it will open a new browser
window and will SSH into my virtual
machine. Yes, now we login into our new
virtual machine. First thing first, we
should first update the packages. I will
run a couple of commands which you can
find it details in the description
section of this video. These commands
will install the required packages
before we start installing the cloud
debot application. First step AP update
then AP upgrade. Just hit yes to install
it. Let's continue with MVM
installation. We will refresh our B
shell. Let's complete our MVM
installation. So we are ready to install
cloud debot. We can install cloud debot
application with just one line of
command. You can find this command in
the cloud debot web page. I'm just
copying this command and let's run this
command. It will take a couple of
minutes for cloud debot installation
completes. Okay, now we are ready to
onboard cloudbot. First, select yes to
understand that this is a powerful and
risky application. Select the quick
start mode. Okay, now this is the most
important part. You need to select a
model and provide an API key for that
model. As I mentioned before, you need
to pay for the LLM that you will use.
For this demo, I am going to use my
Google Gemini account. So, I am
selecting Google and I will provide my
Google Gemini API key. To generate a
Google Gemini API key, go to the
aistudio.google.com.
Click the API key section and generate a
API key from here. Since I already
generated an API key, I will use that
key. Provide your Gemini API key here
and click enter. After you inserted your
API key, then you need to select the
model. To keep it cost effective, I will
use the flash models. I tried to use
Gemini 1.5 flash model, but it doesn't
working with cloud debot. So, I will use
the Gemini 2.5 flash version, which
looks like the most cost effective
version. Okay. Now, let's connect the
chat application to our bot. I will use
Telegram in this demo. Creating a
Telegram bot and generating a bot token
from Telegram is very easy. We will
follow the following steps. So, first go
to Telegram and find bot father. Create
a new bot. Give a name to your bot and
create the bot and copy the API token.
Once you get the token, paste the token
and click enter. You can skip
configuring the skills part. You can
also skip configuring the hooks part.
Then it will install the gateway and
start it. You can select the first edge
to configure your bot. The bot will ask
you a couple of questions such as what
will be the name of the bot, what kind
of creature is the bot, what will be the
tone of the conversation, and what will
be the bot's emoji. And then you can
provide some information related to
yourself. Okay, I will fill the details
now. So I gave the following prompt.
Your name is my arcadesh and you are my
best friend. You can be act like that
and my name is John. You can call me
John. To be able to use the telegram
bot, you need to pair the telegram bot
with cloud debot. So it will give you a
pairing code. Just share it with cloud
debot. Once you pair the telegram bot
with the cloud debot, you can continue
chatting with the bot through telegram.
So from now on I will use telegram to
chat with my bot. How is the weather
today? I'm in Ria and please provide
Celsius degree. Great. I am able to chat
with the bot and it give me the weather
information. Okay let's make the bot
more useful. I want to use this bot as a
second brain. So I want to connect my
bot to my notion workspace. Then I will
give some instruction to the bot and it
will directly write into the notion
workspace. To be able to connect your
bot to notion, just write I want to
connect to my notion workspace and the
bot will give you some guidance about
how to connect. It's actually very easy.
Go to notion's integrations and create
an integration and generate an API key
and give that API key to the bot. I
already configured my bot with the API
key of notion. Now I will give the bot
some instructions and let's see what
will happen. By the way, I also added
the Brave search API to the bot. With
this API, the bot is able to search from
the internet. It is very easy to
connect. Go to brave search API portal
and create an API key and give that API
key to your bot and then it will be able
to search in the internet freely. So
let's make an example. Hi my Araadesh,
tomorrow I will have a job interview for
a data engineer role. Can you please
search some frequent test questions and
some and some guideline documents for me
and please add those information to my
notion workspace? Thanks. Okay, the bot
started investigating for some
frequently asked information for the
data engineer role. Let's wait a little.
Great. The bot successfully added the
information to my notion page. Let's
check it. Excellent. When I check my
notion workspace, I can see that the bot
edited some information for the data
engineering rule interview preparation.
There are some interview questions and
answers. So I can easily go to those
pages and check the details. Excellent
job my archadash. Thanks. So finally you
have it. You just built a secure private
AI agent on AWS that runs 724. I have
left all the required comments in the
description below. If you want to see
more videos about building your own AI
tools instead of just paying for the
subscription, hit the subscribe button.